somewhere in a field by the coast in the
north of england
is britain's best kept industrial secret
it looks like a vision of the fossil
fuel past but this refinery is one of
the answers to one of the biggest
questions of all how to eliminate carbon
emissions and to save the planet
if that sounds unexpected
then it is because this is the story of
where batteries come from
and this increasingly the biggest
economic issue of the 21st century
is probably not the story you think it
is
okay
[Music]
the london metal exchange for more than
a century this is where the world has
come to buy and sell in the ring so this
board has been kind of going like
haywire it's been flashing a lot that's
right yeah
today it is the pursuit of critical
materials to fuel a new green industrial
revolution that's taking financial
markets by storm
or if the world is in a race for
critical materials this in a sense is
one of the front lines
where the prices of those metals
are being set
we've seen a phenomenal increase in
demand for the likes of lithium and and
cobalt there's a lot of investment uh
flowing into the sector as you might
imagine and clearly prices have been uh
have been extremely volatile in recent
years
this is about money it's about jobs
it's about the fate of the planet
because to some extent they all depend
on these things batteries
cells
whether in your smartphone or in an
electric car they are the energy source
of the future
but how are they actually made and
what's inside them
to answer that i've traveled to the one
place in the uk where we have the
equipment to make them where you have to
wear protective clothing not to protect
you from the machines
but to protect the machines from you
here at uk bit we'll make a 21 700 self
so
21 millimeters in diameter 70 mil long
used in lots of electronic components so
laptops things like that
if everything goes to plan there will
soon be a lot more of these machines
around the country in a fleet of
so-called gigafactories massive plants
taking critical metals and turning them
into batteries
well what is a battery ultimately it is
those raw materials crucial materials
like lithium cobalt and so on rolled up
into this coil that in turn then gets
covered in steel and becomes that cell
that we all recognize and this place
here in coventry the battery
industrialization center is a place
where companies will come and learn how
to build the gigafactories of the future
is this kind of high value manufacturing
when you're talking about batteries um
yes it is so it's a very it's very
skilled it's very capital intensive as
well so to build the factories in the
first place costs billions of pounds and
there's been some recent announcements
in the uk
a couple of giga factories that are
going ahead but what you've got here is
kind of the closest thing to a
gigafactory that that we have really
isn't it it is the closest thing we've
got to a gigafactory in the uk all of
the equipment that we've got here ed is
the kind of equipment you would find in
a gigafactory
this is a typical cell a cylindrical
cell okay there are various different
forms of cell which we can show you yeah
sure
so these are the kind of cells that
we're making for our clients at the
moment we make different formats um this
could go in an electric car yeah so in
an electric car so um typically in a
large electric car battery there may be
seven or eight thousand of these cells
but it's only when you look inside the
batteries that you begin to see the
materials the world is racing to procure
and inside there we've got then
layers of
layers of cathode or anode in that case
and cathode material you can now see
that unwinding and you can see those
layers so so one side is the side that
is in this case a graphite and the other
side is that's that's your graphite
that's your and then that's your kind of
lithium and other things that's that's
exactly right amazing
but there is a problem because according
to internal calculations provided to the
government and seen by sky news
britain's gigafactory ambitions may fall
short of what it needs at present the uk
has about two gigawatt hours of battery
production by 2030 it is projected to
have about 70 but if it wants to keep
the car industry in its current state
and protect jobs it may need more than
double that 175
hours
and given batteries are all about the
interaction between the materials in
that cathode and anode positive and
negative it will also need enormous
quantities of cobalt procured from ores
like cobaltite and lithium the heart of
the battery so volatile it can only be
processed when turned into salt like
lithium carbonate
the leaked data shows the uk's
requirements for lithium cobalt and
graphite for anodes currently the bars
are so small you can barely see them by
2030 they could be 90 times higher a 9
000 increase
raising a question where will it all
come from
currently most of the world's lithium
comes from the deserts in australia and
here in chile before being transported
all around the world usually via china
we've built the pile of plant in it
how is britain doing on this front
to find out i've traveled to cornwall
where the most promising reserves are to
be found
[Music]
the starting process is we take the
crush rock which we feed into the plant
it goes up the conveyor belt we've got
this whole process processed up there
yeah it's all refined and then this is
it this is the end product the final uh
lithium carbonate so that's lithium
carbonate that's it there and that's
stuff that you could put straight into a
into a well
a cathode which goes into a battery and
that's the key ingredient yeah
about four mobile phones just here it's
a bit of a transformation to take it
from that to that
of course this is just a demonstration
plant but this company like many in the
sector has big dreams it's totally a
lithium gold rush you know no other
commodity on the planet is growing by 30
40
per year if you look at the uk we've got
a 96 billion pound automotive industry
and that's transitioning by 2030 to
completely electric vehicles so where
are we going to get all of these
batteries and in turn where are we going
to get all this lithium to supply those
batteries
and it's not just lithium there are
other materials in those cathodes too
nickel manganese and most notoriously
cobalt
[Applause]
scenes from a sky news investigation
five years ago in a cobalt mine where
children as young as four are put to
work
a very high proportion of cobalt is
mined in the democratic republic of
congo so it's concentrated in one
country it's concentrated in a country
that is quite a high political risk
potentially
and then added to that are the headlines
that you sometimes see that some of the
minds are using child labour and that
adds to the what we call the
environmental social governance risk
that goes with
it
but remember the cathode is only one
half of the battery what about the anode
what's that made of
the answer it turns out is graphite
graphite not lithium is the single
biggest ingredient in the batteries in
smartphones and cars like this one and
where does that graphite come from some
is mined mostly in china but some comes
from somewhere much closer to home
this is the humber refinery where they
make petrol aviation fuel and it turns
out the critical ingredient that goes
into
anodes it is the first time anyone has
been allowed in to film this process
at the heart of the global battery
supply chain
we are quite literally in the bowels of
britain's fossil fuel industry there is
soot
caked everywhere the air is thick with a
kind of acrid steam
and it's all coming
from this stuff this
is graphite coke and surprising as this
might sound it is central to resolving
climate change and getting to net zero
why because pretty much every battery
and every electric car in the world
contains that stuff in the anode and
what is that made from
crude oil
this
is the reality of green energy the bit
no one really talks about
because the black substance you're
looking at here will soon be part of the
batteries powering the energy transition
if you have an iphone the chances are it
has some of this north sea carbon in it
we've got
four pairs of coat drums so we're
halfway at one pair looking across
another pair
and what happens here is that the uh
the coke forms in a vertical solid drum
once the drums full of coke
we cool it down
with water which you can see the steam
coming out there so that's the coke down
there it is that's the black looks like
coal
aren't you part of the you know the
problem in the there's all these
chimneys here
pumping out a lot of pollution that will
turn your statement around i like to say
we're part of the solution we're not the
problem
even that zero is powered in part by
fossil fuels but this is not burning
them it's making stuff with them and i'm
usually doing it here we're the only
people in the uk that's manufacturing
and really the only people at any scale
in europe and so you know really for the
uk it's a significant opportunity we've
got one piece
of the supply chain right here around us
you know right now it all gets exported
to the other side of the world there are
you know lots of know-how involved and
trade secrets but we've been doing it
for a long time so manufacturer of high
grade petroleum coke it might look like
coal and you see it lying around but
i'll show you it isn't it's it's very
specialized with very specialized and
very tightly controlled properties
that brings us to a question right now
we ship this coke from humberside to
china to be turned into anodes why
aren't we doing that here it is another
race the uk is not winning
which is ironic because this country is
where the battery story really began
the ev revolution started just a couple
of hundred yards from where we're
sitting right here today in in oxford
with the discovery by john goodenough of
lithium cobalt oxide but if we want to
be a leader
we're going to have to leapfrog to the
next generation because you know other
countries china japan etc south korea
they already are very dominant in
lithium ion technology
uh so we can certainly play our part
there
but the opportunity for the uk to be a
world leader you know to be a a
superpower is to look to the next
generation and that would be something
like the solid state battery there's
also the sodium ion battery
sodium ion batteries where the main
ingredient isn't hard to source lithium
but sodium chloride table salt
and guess what the world leader in
sodium iron is based here in sheffield
we start with our two active materials
so we have a negative active material
which is our anode and a positive which
is our cathode and at the moment our
sodium is in our cathode
and our anode is basically carbon
so no lithium no copper no cobalt the
only problem is these batteries aren't
quite as powerful as lithium ones
we think that sodium ion gives the
opportunity for the uk to go beyond
lithium to get out in front of the next
generation of technology does it feel
like a race it's an arms race right i
mean if you look at oil it's
geopolitical it was an arms race right
it's all about energy security in many
ways it's not just about the market but
it's about energy security that's
national security it's economic security
it's environmental security
and where is britain in that race does
the uk have a critical mineral strategy
at the moment at the moment there's no
critical mineral strategy in the uk
it should have one
and the uk government
are working on that at the moment
we stand at the dawn of a new industrial
revolution
and a new great race for materials bets
are being placed europe is beating us to
the point
how our battery industry evolves may
shape our economy hundreds of thousands
of jobs in the uk depend on the
automotive sector if we as a country
can't have some of that technology here
then we lose out
[Music]
our lives our livelihoods
our security you want to have control
over your own destiny in terms of your
energy
this unexpected story of batteries and
metals of green power sources made in
fossil fuel plants
is not over it is about to begin
[Music]